[Musique]
je m'appelle youth heures j'ai 25 ans je
suis tout juste diplômé de l'école
nationale de la statistique
ici j'ai appris à traiter les données ce
que tout le monde appelle maintenant la
data les données jeu c'est d'élire les
interpréter et je veux m'en servir pour
le bien commun mais avant d'espérer
changé de monde il faut comprendre d'où
l'on vient
[Musique]
et justement dans mon école il ya un
sujet tableau elle a été créée en 1942
sous le régime de vichy
pas vraiment la période la plus
glorieuse de l'histoire de france et je
ne suis pas la seule étudiante que cela
entre hig
[Musique]
c'est ainsi que j'ai décidé d'enquêter
sur rené carmi deux fondateurs de notre
école
parce que je lisais tout et son
contraire sur lui
pour certains il aurait contribué à la
déportation des juifs ah non en fait
selon d'autres il en aurait sauvé j'ai
même lu que c'était le premier à coeur
de l'histoire
et bon sang je m'imaginais pas que ça
allait être aussi compliqué mes enfants
bien su que j'allais faire un interview
ils m'ont dit on y va surtout pas c'est
vrai ça va être encore un mythe d
horreur ils étaient étonnés là
que j'ai accepté le truc parce que bon
savent qu'ils savent les polémiques qui
a pu avoir
françois tu te retrouvais dans un panier
de crabes dont je vais vous dire mon
conseil et puis que je vous donne
entre est pas là dedans
soyez le plus neutre possible
ceux qui parlent le plus c'est qu'ils
braillent le plus n'y connaissent rien
[Musique]
en plus de mon école rené carmi a fondé
ce qui deviendra l'institut national de
la statistique et des études économiques
et surtout on lui doit tous quelque
chose c'est lui qui a inventé notre
numéro de sécurité sociale et ça
personne ne le sait
pourquoi est-ce que l'histoire l'a
oublié est ce que rené car mis à jouer
un rôle dans la politique antisémite de
vichy
ou est ce qu'il a au contraire combattu
les nazis
la seule chose que je sache pour
l'instant c'est qu'il est mort en
déportation à dachau à la fin de la
guerre mais je ne sais pas pourquoi
[Musique]
bon reprenons depuis le début été 1940
pétain signe l'armistice avec les
allemands qui occupe toute la partie
nord du pays
tout ça je le savais déjà mais ce que je
ne savais pas c'est que de gaulle n'a
pas été le seul à vouloir se poser à
hitler dans l'entourage du maréchal
pétain à vichy quelques officiels
réfléchissent eux aussi à une possible
contre attaque
il ya un certain nombre d'officiers
supérieurs qui tout en étant favorable à
l'armistice parce qu'ils ne voient pas
d'autre solution politique possible
continue néanmoins à considérer les
allemands comme les comme l'ennemi c'est
à dire là pour l'instant la guerre elle
est terminée c'est s'alarme ici c'est
l'idée que la guerre en métropole est
terminée mais il faut dès maintenant
préparer comme on le peut
cette revanche possible l'étape la plus
urgente style camouflage et matériels
qui convient de faire à chaud et
immédiatement et de trouver
les lieux puisque ce sont des civils qui
vont abriter les caches d'armement
et pour qu'un futur soulèvement contre
l'occupant soit un jour possible il va
falloir identifier tous les hommes prêts
à se battre est capable de se servir de
ses armes
alors comment les trouver une personne a
peut être la solution
l'homme qui a fondé mon école rené
carmine
[Musique]
il est à ce moment là un spécialiste
reconnu de l'organisation de l'armée et
donc dans la perspective de la
recréation de troupes pour
arriver à prendre une revanche
il apparaissait comme je pense comme
l'homme de la situation
alors qu'ils revenaient carmi
ce polytechnicien a grandi en dordogne
où ses parents étaient instituteurs
il s'engage dans la retirer en 1908
participe à la première guerre mondiale
puis grimpe les échelons de l'armée pour
atteindre la fonction de contrôleur
général en 1940 il est une des têtes
pensantes de l'administration militaire
c'est un homme très cultivé et il a des
visions un peu la division politique
disant sur la façon dont il rend peut
gouverner un pays on pourrait qualifier
car mis effectivement d'intellectuels on
peut le qualifier à partir des années 20
des années 30 surtout d'experts parce
que le carmina une idée une ambition qui
est très forte c'est de rationaliser la
gestion des services de l'artillerie il
veut trouver des méthodes des méthodes
qui seront qui vont s'appuyer sur la
mécanographie donc sur un équipement un
équipement baisse ce sont les ancêtres
un des ordinateurs dont qui permettent
de classer des toute une série de
documents
[Musique]
ces machines sont les toutes premières
que l'on peut programmer pour compte et
trier des données et constituer des
fichiers est justement car me pensent
pouvoir s'en servir pour établir la
liste des combattants qui formeront
l'armée secrète que les officiers
revanchard veulent lever en zone libre
alors il leur propose un plan à peine
croyable
pour ne pas éveiller les soupçons des
allemands il veut créer très
officiellement un service national de
statistiques équipés de ces machines qui
servira de couverture à l'opération
clandestine comme ils l'expliquent dans
une note très secrète
c'est là le point secret important le
service de la démographie général peu
préparée dans les conditions de
discrétion maxima les plans de
mobilisation générale
en clair le premier objectif est un
objectif tout à fait officielle il faut
moderniser la statistique moderniser la
statistique comment aux particuliers en
utilisant bas matériel mécanographiques
que quart miami au point pendant toute
la période de l'entre-deux-guerres bon
ça c'est l'objectif officiel objectif
officieux et bien c'est de justement
mettre en place tout un fichier
permettant éventuellement une
remobilisation
de l'armée française et ça effectivement
ça se fait complètement à la barbe des
allemands
ce plan très confidentielle n'est pas
seulement approuvé par quelques
officiers de l'état major selon le fils
de rené carmi aujourd'hui décédé il a
été accepté par pétain lui même une
rencontre a eu lieu à l'été 40
[Musique]
carmi est allé voir les y compris le
maréchal pétain qui lui a dit
comme ça on les revend d'espionnage si
vous vous faites prendre je ne vous
connais pas c'est à dire allez-y mais je
doute que vous aurez tous les crédits
que vous offre que dont vous avez besoin
mais je ne vous couvre pas en cas de
protestation allemande
[Musique]
c'est fou pétant les sphères un projet
résistants ce n'est pas l'image que
j'avais de lui mais bon il ne dit pas
oui pour autant il est en pleine
discussion avec les allemands et en
octobre 1940 il s'engage même à
collaborer
c'est en l'honneur et pour maintenir
l'unité française une unité de dix
siècles dans le cadre inactivité
constructif du nouvel ordre européen le
genre aujourd'hui dans la voie de la
collaboration
collaboré tout en fermant les yeux sur
l'initiative résistante de certains de
ses officiers mais à quoi joue pétain
[Musique]
il ya un certain nombre d'officiers qui
se disent que pétain signe l'armistice
parce qu'il peut pas faire autrement
mais quand son for intérieur pétain veut
préparer la revanche au fond il imagine
que pétain joue une sorte de double jeu
ils négocier avec l'allemagne ici une
armistice mais en même temps en même
temps il n'accepte pas la défaite donc
il va essayer de préparer la revanche et
donc voilà c'est une interprétation
c'est une interprétation cher pétain n'a
jamais dit ça clairement faut être clair
là dessus
toujours est il qu'un mois plus tard en
novembre 1940 le journal officiel publie
le décret fondateur du grand service
civil de statistiques de rené carmine
futur insee qui va servir de couverture
au projet secret de mobilisation en zone
libre
[Musique]
la suite de l'histoire se passe à lyon
c'est là que le tout nouveau service
national de la statistique de rené carmi
s'installe dans cet immeuble de la
presqu'île c'est ici qu'officiellement
il réalisera des études sur la
démographie l'économie le travail car me
prends la tête d'une très grosse
administration
vichy eux c'est un régime qui crée
beaucoup de services qui dépensent
énormément bon mais n'empêche que là on
a effectivement un budget très
conséquent dispose de 1000 hommes à 1000
femmes et hommes et enfin beaucoup plus
d'hommes que de femmes qui sont des
techniciens carmes il s'entoure aussi
immédiatement d'un certain nombre de
militaires qu'il connaît qu'il connaît
bien pour bonnet justement sa mission sa
mission officieuse disons pour produire
de la statistique son service a besoin
d'engranger des données va aller les
chercher partout il fait réaliser un
grand recensement en zone libre qui lui
permet de poser des dizaines de
questions aux français
il fait aussi recopier tous les
registres d'état civil du pays pour
établir la liste complète des français
nés depuis 1880
[Musique]
les petites mains du service de la
démographie se charge ensuite de saisir
dans les machines mécanographiques ces
millions d'informations
il a utilisé lui
l'informatique pour faire quelque chose
qui était très très innovant à l'époque
qui était grosso modo une base de
données nominatives d'individus ça
paraît tout à fait banal aujourd'hui on
en a tous une dans notre agenda son
téléphone mais à l'époque c'était
vraiment le tout premier à faire ce
genre de choses la révolution entre
guillemets car mais il sait que l'on à
des informations nominatives qui sont
tout à fait disponible en permanence
car ces informations nominatives
rené carmi les graver sur des cartes
perforées l'ancêtre de nos disques durs
un trou sur une carte c'est une
information chaque carte pas en
comporter 80 une technologie nouvelle
qui va lui donner une idée en août 1941
son service attribués pour la première
fois en numéro unique à chaque français
rené cormier a été le premier à se dire
on va utiliser un numéro qui va
identifier chaque individu ça paraît
encore une fois très banal aujourd'hui
mais c'était le premier quand vous fait
remplir un formulaire vous mettez votre
date est votre lieu de naissance et
c'est cette date et lieu de naissance
qui sont transformés en chiffres et en
numéro intangible tout au long de votre
vie puisque chacun a une seule date et
lieu de naissance c'est ce qui deviendra
par la suite et ça c'est un héritage non
négligeable 1 2 effectivement de rené
carmi et c'est aussi un résultat de son
expertise c'est le numéro 2 c'est le
fameux numéro de sécurité sociale qui
servira dès 1945 46 1
ce numéro d'identification unique ouvre
une possibilité extraordinaire
grâce à lui les machines de rené car
nice sont capable de croiser avec
facilité toutes les données qui
concernent une même personne même si
elle figure sur différents fichiers le
but de karni de les croiser discrètement
pour en extraire ce qui m'intéresse
vraiment les nuits les adresses
actualisé et les qualifications
militaires des hommes situés en zones
hui ce qui pourrait reprendre le combat
à chaque fois il utilise un prétextes
administratifs plausible c'est pour
lutter contre le chômage qui repère les
activités professionnelles des français
et dans d'autres occasions il crée des
fichiers pour vérifier les primes de
démobilisation les soldats démobilisés
en droit une prime et il ya évidemment
des fraudes contre lesquels il faut
lutter à chaque fois il a une bonne
raison pour créer différents fichiers
qui ont l'air anodin par rapport à la
raison cachée camoufler qui est de créer
des unités militaires il y en a
certainement qui qui ne sont pas dupes
un de mes bons en deux phases en 1941
les allemands ne se sentent pas
tellement menacée par la france et c'est
pas c'est plutôt l'inversé en fait donc
on n'a pas vraiment de craintes à avoir
sur ce plan là
et pourtant quelque chose se prépare
très discrètement chaque semaine venez
carmi peaufine sa stratégie avec l'un
des officiers de l'état major le
lieutenant-colonel heller
l'objectif selon les autorités
militaires qui l'ont fixé au service de
cars mais c'est d'avoir une quinzaine de
division disponibles dans un délai très
court mobilisé près d'un combat le
colonel heller espère que car me
fournissent environ 300000 fiche de
mobilisables l'objectif est ambitieux
mais très risqué
pour y parvenir rené carmi doit faire
saisir et croiser plusieurs fichiers qui
comportent chacun des millions de
données le tout sans qu'aucune des
centaines d'opérateurs est opératrice du
service de la démographie nous remarque
quoi que ce soit
chacun ne connaît que ce qui le concerne
et les opératrices qui gère les fichiers
ne connaissent pas vraiment les usages
des différents fichiers ou ne
connaissent que un seul usage ya le
contrôle des services amant
donc qu'il faut ruser avec l'occupant
qui vient vérifier sert juste ce système
en se réfugiant derrière la technique
pour dissimuler l'autre part de l'action
rené car dit il il a un immense avantage
est que il illustre dans les cours que
je donne à sciences po la résistance du
tecos de la personne qui maîtrise la
technologie et qui dans le système à
pouvoir faire acte de résistance à
travers sa maîtrise de la technologie
ce schéma que je vais surtout pas vous
expliquer et tout simplement l'ancêtre
de nos programmes informatiques actuels
carmi on possède deux exemplaires info à
visée civile qu'il peut montrer aux
allemands et l'autre secret qui permet
le plan de mobilisation
et c'est ça le hac en fait dans des tout
premiers détournement informatique de
l'histoire c'est carmi qui le réalise
un coeur c'est quelqu'un qui contourne
ou détourne une technologie pour en
faire autre chose c'est la définition la
plus large on peut imaginer du hacker
donc à ce titre ouais renée carrier et à
hacker et à ce titre c'est un à un
activiste avec 1h activistes parce qu'il
a contourné détourné une technologie
pour en faire tout autre chose à des
fins de lutte et de résistance
et le plan de rené carmi fonctionne il a
produit le fichier des combattants au
printemps 1942 les cartes perforées sont
prêtes une carte un homme au total plus
d'un mètre cube de données
son arme secrète et au pas
[Musique]
jusque là tout va bien carmi est
irréprochable il a mis ses machines au
service d'un noble combat il voit encore
plus grand avec elle il veut éclairer
l'action de l'état grâce à la
statistique
[Musique]
son service y contribue déjà c'est le
futur insee et pour en former les cadres
en 1942 il crée une école la mienne
l'esn cei
mais voilà il ne s'arrête pas là il
propose un truc fou un projet qu'il
caresse depuis quelques années déjà il
veut constituer pour chaque français ce
qu'ils appellent un carnet signalétique
individuel
conçu avec le ministère de l'intérieur
ce carnet doit comporter plusieurs
rubriques
instructions générales et activités
intellectuelles
activité professionnelle prévoyance
sociale profil psychologique
quasi-judiciaire domicile et résidents
successifs
relations avec l'étranger et enfin les
séjours dans les camps de jeunesse
il veut organiser un recensement
permanent c'est à dire pouvoir connaître
à la minute tout le temps avec des
informations qu'ils sont des
informations actualisées
systématiquement toute la population qui
est la population du territoire le
meilleur parallèle finalement avec le
carnet signalétique de karmi c'est
probablement aujourd'hui
ce profil informatique mathématiques que
recompose les grandes plateformes combat
sur facebook sur google sur instagram
compile finalement
double informatique à profil qui nous
échappe qui ne nous appartient pas qui
est assez opaque en d'ailleurs c'est un
miroir sans tain ils nous voient mais on
ne voit pas beaucoup mais effectivement
c'est ce qui est probablement le plus
proche de ceux de ce carnet cinétique
aujourd'hui
des données des données est encore plus
de données certes elles sont utiles pour
identifier les mobilisables et peut-être
un jour combattre mais pour les obtenir
carmi s'engouffre dans tous les projets
de vichy la toute nouvelle carte
d'identité à laquelle il veut ajouter
son numéro d'identification
la loi qui rend obligatoire la
déclaration de changement de domicile
qu'il soutient que des projets dangereux
là on est en effet dans un engrenage qui
est je veux des informations pour
actualiser et il m'en faut de plus en
plus l'histoire a montré que
service statistique qu'il soit public ou
qu'il soit privé avait quand même
tendance à devenir assez naturellement
est assez spontanément
acquisiton real justement c'est à dire
que que ce soit à l'histoire récente
était grande plateforme facebook par
exemple où que ce soit l'histoire des
fichiers de police qui ne cesse jamais
grandir
sorte d'obésité morbide de ces fichiers
où ils ne réduisent jamais la voilure
mais ne cesse de s'étendre de
s'interconnecter de ce combiné etc on
est dans l'accumulation on n'est jamais
dans la dans leurs retranchements dans
le dans la diminution est donc à partir
de là ça présente un certain nombre de
dangers
[Musique]
irréalisable et techniquement le projet
de carnets signalétique individuelle ne
va pas aboutir le rêve de karmi d'un
fichage total de la population
réactualisée en permanence ne se
réalisera pas de son vivant en tout cas
[Musique]
mais là on est en 41 42 il y à cette
question qui m'obsède et que maintenant
je ne peux plus laissé de côté
carmi at il aussi voulu fiche et les
juifs
c'est en tout cas ce que les historiens
ont avancé dans les années 90
[Musique]
la famille à penser que la mémoire de
mon grand-père était injustement
attaquée c'est tout moi je ne sais pas
je ne sais que ce qui a été écrit par
les uns ou par les autres
les uns ou les autres ce sont des
historiens ou des personnes qui comme
moi ont croisé rené carmi au fil de leur
parcours
michel lui lévis et retraités de l'insee
et s'intéresse au sujet depuis plus de
50 ans pour des raisons très
personnelles il est né pendant la guerre
et a d'abord vécu sous une fausse
identité
quand je suis allé dans une école
maternelle j'avais cinq ans deux
premiers noms que j'ai écrits de mon nom
de famille c'est luciani et quand
l'année suivante en est revenue à paris
et que on m'a dit que je m'appelais lévy
sa batteuse traumatisé s'il faut se dire
et je comprenais pas pourquoi je devais
changer de nom et donc quand je suis
devenu
statisticiens en 62 64 me suis intéressé
à est ce que les fichiers que carmi
avait créé était
avait servi à quelque chose dans la
persécution des juifs dans mes parents
et moi même si je veux dire avions été
victime pendant l'occupation
bon je vous raconte dans le recensement
lancé en 1941 prétexte d'étudier le
chômage n'est qu'un me pose beaucoup
beaucoup de questions
trente et une question au total nom
prénom profession adresse
et puis il ya la question 11
etes-vous de race juive
ce qui est intéressant quand on regarde
les différents documents administratifs
qui ont été constitués par les
administrations sous vichy on se rend
compte d'une chose à de très rares
exceptions près il n'y a pas d'
instructions venant de l'état de faire
de la mention juifs de une norme
intégrés dans les différents formulaires
que quelqu'un comme terme ils
choisissent de faire figurer cette
information montre que lui intègre
l'antisémitisme comme étant une
politique d'état il pourrait la laisser
à des cas personne ne l'a forcé jusqu'à
démonstration du contraire de l'intégrer
[Musique]
je crois que c'est une question qui a dû
paraître jeudi pas de dean mais normal
dans l'état de la législation de
l'époque c'était naturel si j'ose dire
de poser cette question
[Musique]
car milan n'a pas fait grand chose pour
autant qu'on sache ce qu'il a peut-être
fait c'est de d'utiliser cette question
pour des fichiers particulier dont celui
des chantiers de jeunesse et dans ce cas
là c'était pour dispenser les juifs cas
qui en interdisaient d'aller aux
chantiers de jeunesse les résultats de
cette question ils n'ont pas été
exploités parce que au même moment à peu
près au même moment se crée un
commissariat se créer une institution
spéciale qui est destiné justement à
organiser le recensement des juifs
donc le plus grand danger ce ne sont pas
tant les questions de karmi que celle de
l'institution chargée d'exécuter la
politique antisémite de vichy le haut
commissariat à la question juillet à
l'été 41 son chef xavier vallat
s'apprête à recenser les juifs là encore
l'attitude de cars me pose problème
le 18 juin il propose ses services à
xavier vallat et en des termes on ne
peut plus clair
[Musique]
dans le cas où le modèle des bulletins
de recensement des juifs ne serait pas
définitivement établi je me tiens à
votre disposition pour réunir tous les
renseignements utiles sur les juifs et
en définitive être éclairé exactement
sur le problème juif
[Musique]
trois jours plus tard la réponse de
xavier vallat arrive il est dans
l'urgence et ne veut pas perdre du temps
avec une exploitation mécanographiques
des données
une semaine plus tard car me renouvelle
sa proposition et s'engage à en faire un
traitement quasi instantanée et pourquoi
carmi insiste-t-il
la réponse est peut-être à paris où un
autre service de statistiques
antérieures à celui de karni essaie de
lui faire de l'ombre pas question de se
laisser doubler par son concurrent
lorsque rené car me propose les services
de la démographie pour exploiter le
recensement des juifs de juin 1941
henri paul qui est le directeur de
l'autre service de la statistique a déjà
proposé des services les deux directeurs
de ces services de statistiques
défendent ainsi l'existence même de
leurs services en fait y ait une
compétition entre des administrations et
qui a remis joue cette compétition là ça
ne démontre absolument rien d'autre que
l'on a affaire à quelqu'un qui veut
faire briller sa propre administration
il montrait l'intérêt de son
administration il faut pas perdre de vue
cela c'est que chaque administration
doit montrer qu'elle sert à quelque
chose si elle ne sert à rien alors elle
peut être dissoute
rené carmi serait donc rentrer dans la
logique antisémite pour donner de
l'importance à son service en jeu
dangereux car en décembre 1941 xavier
vallat submergé par les données fini par
accepter la proposition de karni le
service de la statistique va donc
s'occuper du fichier des juifs
mais là contre toute attente le
traitement du fichier va là ne va pas
aussi vite que prévu
carmi est il lui aussi noyé par les
données à moins que le ralentissement ne
soit volontaire
j'ai fait interroger des gens qui
avaient déjà été en service pendant
l'occupation
quelles étaient leurs souvenirs de cette
opération et tout le monde était
d'accord il ya des sous témoignages
concordants pour rappeler qu' il fallait
ralentir au plus possible toute cette
activité concernant les juifs il ya des
anecdotes sur esque veille les troncs
wail qu'etat juif bien connu pour de
zèle ou un mail ou deux y alors que des
madame veil lequel est écrit avec un je
vais donc ce genre de complications sur
l'orthographe simplement du nom
permettait d'avoir des prétextes simple
pour et qui fait qu'il y ait
éventuellement une volonté au bout d'un
moment
de fos et sept instruments là c'est une
possibilité qui n'est attesté en fait
que par quelques témoignages mais
surtout
qui n'est pas validée par autre chose
c'est là dessus que bute les historiens
parce qu'il n'y a pas de traces sauf que
le témoignage des personnels qui les
avait reçus et appliqué me voilà perdu
presque comme au début de mes recherches
faut-il croire à ces témoignages post
libération difficile à vérifier
ou resté sidéré par les lettres de karmi
avala
ralentissements volontairement en tout
cas les services de rené carmi n'ont
jamais délivré deux versions nominatif
du fichier vallat qui auraient pu être
utilisées à des fins policières
tout ce qu'ils ont produit c'est une
étude statistique sur les juifs en
france sans le moindre nous prennons
remise au commissariat général à la
question juive très tardivement en août
[Musique]
mais alors comment interpréter les
intentions de carmine entre la question
11 les lettres aval à ce ralentissement
sur lequel les historiens s'interrogent
les trous archivistique empêchent de
conclure complètement sûr mais justement
la conscience ou non des dangers de
cette cet appareillage qui aurait très
bien pu tomber au service finalement ou
bien une politique antisémite ou bien
d'une politique de lutte contre la
résistance ou ce genre de choses c'est
très difficile de conclure parce qu'on
ne dispose pas et malheureusement je
pense qu'on ne disposera jamais de
l'intégralité des archives qui
permettent de faire vraiment la part des
choses
peut-être qu'un jour au fond d'une cave
d'un grenier on retrouvera une référence
au service national de la statistique
qui nous éclairera un peu plus
l'histoire n'est pas figé et si
aujourd'hui un portrait de karmi se
dessine avec ce que l'on sait de lui sa
lecture n'est pas la même pour tout le
monde
depuis toujours je me pose la question
est ce que les fichiers de karmi ont
servi en quoi que ce soit à la
persécution des juifs ma réponse est non
il n'a pas prêté la main la persécution
mais je doute qu'ils aient véritablement
sauvé des juifs tout au plus at-il
retardé peut-être les missions du
commissariat général aux questions
juives qui était plutôt d'émissions de
spoliation il s'agit pas de dire que
carmi est l'équivalent pétanque c'est la
pierre des crapules sous vichy c'est
absolument pas le cas on a affaire à
quelqu'un qui ressemble à une myriade
d'autres hauts fonctionnaires qui n'a
pas eu problème dans un premier temps
d'appliquer une politique qui est
totalement anormale au regard de
l'histoire de france qui en 41 et en 42
fait valoir la qualité de son service
son savoir-faire et essaye de montrer à
quel point il est utile pour l'état et
pour les tâches de l'état et ensuite à
partir de 43 on rentre dans une autre
histoire
[Musique]
qui paie
revenons à la grande histoire
je vous
1942 est une année de bascule la guerre
s'est mondialisée hitler se bat
désormais contre l'armée rouge sur le
front est
les américains qui sont entrés dans le
conflit enchaîne les victoires au japon
et de bi novembre 1942 c'est l'opération
torch les alliés débarquent en algérie
française carmille le jour où il apprend
le débarquement anglo-américain en
afrique du nord algérie novembre 42
d'abord il est fou de joie ce qui est
important parce que ça fait qu'il est
contre les américains et les anglais des
bas mais quand la conséquence c'est
l'invasion de la zone sud par lé trophée
allemand ça devient une catastrophe
puisque tous ces efforts de camouflage
risque de tomber aux mains des allemands
trois jours après le débarquement en
représailles l'allemagne envahit la zone
libre et occupent ainsi l'ensemble de la
france la wehrmacht patrouillent
désormais dans lyon
[Musique]
pour se protéger des allemands permis en
voit deux de ses proches collaborateurs
dissimuler les données compromettantes
dans un séminaire jésuites de la
banlieue lyonnaise il caresse l'espoir
de pouvoir les réutiliser très vite
le signal ne saurait par b
[Musique]
hélas là il ya un certain nombre
d'officiers qui pensent que pétain va
quitter enfin la france a quitté la
métropole pour aller se réfugier par un
plomb en afrique du nord
et reprendre la lune depuis l'afrique du
nord et dans cette perspective là
effectivement
bas toutes les actions qui ont été
menées par un certain par ses officiers
supérieurs de l'armée d'espionnage de
camouflage de fichiers de mobilisation
etc
tout ça ça peut cristalliser ça peut
devenir réel sauf que sauf que c'est pas
ce qui se passe sauf que pétain ne part
pas en afrique du nord
sauf que pétain ne s'oppose pas
[Musique]
à
prenez carmille est entièrement
résolument l'ennemi c'est l'allemand on
tour déduire après novembre 1942 sa
déconvenue
de l'attitude du chef de l'état ceci dit
tente le tout pour le tout il espère
pendant quelques semaines que pétain que
l'armée française va réagir contre le
coup de force allemand est une de ces
manifestations dont on a des témoignages
c'est que il fait faire une
démonstration
au maréchal pétain lui même de des
possibilités de ces machines
mécanographiques
la rencontre a lieu un peu moins d'un
mois après l'invasion de la zone libre
un témoin la raconte
à l'issue de la visite monsieur carmi il
a décrit en détail le fonctionnement et
l'emploi possible de ces fichiers
monsieur carmi exposants qu'on pouvait
réunir les éléments de plusieurs
divisions le maréchal a demandé combien
mais pétain ne donnera aucune suite si
carmi est prêt fichier ne l'est pas il
ne l'a d'ailleurs jamais été
c'est un fait qui a pas eu double jeu
que l'an revanche c'était une illusion
même si parfois
le gouvernement de vichy a pu fermer les
yeux sur certaines choses en tous les
cas il a choisi et que le camp et est
bien celui de l'allemagne vichy c'est
c'est le contraire de la résistance donc
il ya un moment en fait tous les deux
termes sont la contradiction est trop
forte donc on ne peut pas être les deux
simultanément on peut peut-être lettres
ou penser l'être jusqu'à un certain
point mais il ya un moment où c'est plus
possible
et donc oui à ce moment là pour basculer
vraiment dans la résistance il faut
quitter vichy
il faut quitter vichy
pour cars mini c'est l'heure des choix
est-ce qu'il faut tout abandonné quitter
son poste oubliez le fichier des
mobilisables tous ces risques pour rien
à moins qu'il puisse être utile là où il
est
la résistance a tout intérêt à compter
dans ses rangs des gens qui occupent ses
positions
et les grands mouvements de résistance
d'ailleurs ne s'y trompe pas il met en
place des structures de noyautage des
administrations publiques
et dès janvier 1943 il est sollicité par
un réseau résistants de zone sud le
réseau marco polo en réseau de
renseignement gaulliste
cette résistance c'est celle qu'on
apprend tous en cours d'histoire celle
des maquis des posteurs radio des faux
papiers
[Musique]
venez carmi est recruté par une dactylo
de son service
d'après ce que nous disent diverses
sources archivistiques rené quarts mais
a recruté par
parcelle qu'on appellera jacky
[Musique]
probablement qu'elle a une relation de
confiance avec rené carmille qu'elle a
pu un petit peu détecter son sentiment
par rapport aux allemands son sentiment
par rapport à la résistance au sein du
service des statistiques
au sein du réseau il va lui donner un
grade de sous-lieutenant ce qui est un
grade assez bas dans la hiérarchie
militaire qui ne correspond en rien avec
son grade très élevé officiel malgré
tout au sein du réseau
il a il semble avoir une place assez
importante
c'est à dire qu'il est il est considéré
comme un vip on le considère comme à
quelqu'un qui a une place officielle
très élevé donc c'est on le ménage en
faire attention à sa parole on fait
attention à ce qu'il dit
ils les aident les plus précieuses que
fournit rené car nous ce sont de faux
papiers réalisé avec des identités de
personnes décédées une information
connue de son service c'est très
certainement jacky son agent de liaison
qui les fait parvenir aux résistants ou
aux juifs pourchassés
elle transmet aussi des renseignements
stratégiques
notez par carmi
ce qu'ils pouvaient fournir
officiellement à son administration à sa
hiérarchie il pouvait également les
fournir en même temps au réseau pour que
les réseaux et laurent consécutivement
et les mêmes types de renseignements ça
pouvait être toutes sortes de
statistiques en fait sur même économique
enfin démographique sur le
les personnes requises pour le service
du travail obligatoire
on peut pas se mettre dans la tête de
karmi mais
d'après les sources archivistiques
d'après les témoignages qu'on a la
pression voilà que l'engagement de karni
rester très fort
en mai 1943 rené car me fait un discours
aux étudiants de polytechnique un
discours très solennel un appel à la
liberté
[Musique]
aucune force au monde ne peut vous
empêcher de vous rappeler que vous êtes
les héritiers de ceux qui ont défendu le
sol de france souvenez vous en
aucune force au monde ne peut vous
empêcher de savoir que la liberté de
pensée a toujours existé sur la montagne
sainte-geneviève avec rigueur et
ténacité
souvenez vous en
mais carmi est enthousiaste
qu'en tunisie les soldats alliés
viennent de remporter une victoire parmi
eux des combattants français mobilisés
grâce au bureau algérois du service de
la statistique
une réussite enfin
s'il ya un endroit où la mobilisation
clandestine prévu par cpt a remis a
servi c'est à alger
elle a servi à la mobilisation des
armées françaises qui ont contribué en
tunisie à lutter contre le maréchal
rommel qui a occupé la tunisie en 43
points ce qui concerne le fonctionnement
précis en afrique du nord on n'est pas
en mesure me semble t'il alors apple en
fonction de l'état actuel des archies
donne connaissance d un fils d'aller
plus loin mais cela fonctionnait
en métropole car me espère que son
dispositif pourra servir un autre
débarquement très prudemment il continue
de chercher à identifier des hommes
mobilisables
[Musique]
vous
c'est seulement d'or la fin 43 le
deuxième semestre 43 que les allemands
commencent à se douter que ses activités
servent aussi à préparer des
mobilisations particulière de
spécialistes notamment qui devrait
servir aux armées alliées donc qui se
douter progressivement il est mise en
surveillance ci lui dit rené le car mais
n'est pas très à l'aise au niveau de
l'institut national des statistiques
parce que le chef du personnel et sans
doute d'autres personnes sondées
collaborateur notoire dont
le social de personnels qui sont utiles
un responsable de la milice rené que la
remise donc là sans cesse peur de faire
des maladresses et ce sans même
espionner à l'intérieur d'eux
de l'institut que je dirige
l'étau policier se resserre mais ce
n'est pas tout les administrations de
vichy tente de récupérer les fichiers du
service de statistiques on lui demande
de fournir des listes de jeune homme a
envoyé en allemagne au service du
travail obligatoire le st lô
carmi le sens bien sont utiles lui
échappe ultime geste de bravoure ou de
désespoir le 24 janvier 1944 il tente de
s'opposer aux requêtes de vie fier
j'attire votre attention sur le fait que
mon service et astreints au secret
professionnel et que ses attributions
sont purement statistique à l'exclusion
de tout rôle de police c'est assez
intéressant que karmil et plaidé pour
une utilisation policière de ces de ces
informations là parce qu'au final
c'était assez c'était assez inéluctable
en france on parle de l'effet cliquet il
sera expliqué qu'une fois que le
mécanisme est enclenché il n'y a pas de
retour en arrière les anglo saxons un
autre terme qui est un peu différent il
parle de michonne clip est en fait le
mishan clip ça désigne le détournement
de finalité c'est à dire que ce fichier
une technologie qui est utilisé pour
répondre à un besoin à un instant t
pourra demain être utilisé à d'autres
fins
le 3 février 1944 la gestapo vient
arrêter rené carmi dans son bureau il
sera désigné comme grand ennemi de
l'armée allemande ayant entretenu des
relations avec londres et aider des
groupes terroristes
mais qui appuient dénoncer car mire
[Musique]
deux jours auparavant jacky l'agent qui
l'a engagé dans le réseau marco polo
s'est fait arrêter elle au site
il ya des témoignages qui ne sont pas
vraiment à son avantage j'espère que
jacky a une relation avec un officier
allemand de la prison montluc qu'elle va
aux interrogatoires mais qu'elle revient
à la souriante
épanouie et par ailleurs il ya un
témoignage assez précis d'une co détenu
à la prison montluc qui explique qu'elle
a sur la conscience l'arrestation d'un
général il se général c'est sans doute
freiné car mon quart général c'est son
pseudo dans le réseau
la fin elle est clair maintenant
[Musique]
incarcéré à la prison de montluc sonné
carmi est interrogé par les services
lyonnais de la gestapo dirigé par klaus
barbie les interrogatoires dure jusqu'à
tard le soir et carmi est malmené eelv a
passé quatre mois en détention il y
écrit une lettre à sa femme qu'il fait
transmettre secrètement par un détenu
libéré
un
sonnet qui a été composée par la carmi
alors qu'il était à montluc dans la
prison et qui a été sorti dans l'ourlet
d'un manteau c'est un sonnet dédié à sa
femme qui est très émouvant pour tenu du
contexte carmi était un homme qui avait
beaucoup de sentiments et qui aimait
beaucoup sa femme
[Musique]
à ma femme 30 ans ont passé depuis notre
mariage les roses de l'amour n'ont pas
voulu fanées et leurs pétales d'or ont
toujours dominé le calme alanguie sens
où le vent de l'orage et nous avons
passé tout le temps de cet âge en un
monde explosant en débris disloqué où
les peuples en fureur par satan convoqué
montrait dans leur laideur ce qu'elle
humaine rage le grand amour le nôtre est
aussi rédempteur de l'humaine folie
l'espoir de nos coeurs a su demeurer
forts parmi tous ceux qui passent
[Musique]
le 2 juillet 1944 comme des milliers de
résistants rené carmi est déporté à
dachau dans un convoi tristement célèbre
le train de la mort qui vise 500
prisonniers mourir d'étouffement et de
déshydratation
paris libéré le 25 août 1944 mais les
combats ne sont pas terminés et les
camps encore moins libérée mais carmi ne
tiendra pas jusqu'à la fin de la guerre
il meurt du typhus le 25 janvier 1945 un
de ses camarades de déportation
témoignera
c'est dans la nudité la misère
l'abjection physique bien loin de son
lit que le contrôleur général car me
rendis le dernier soupir
[Musique]
il déchante jusque maintenant vers nani
c'est que et bien que la guerre est un
système de sélection par le bas
c'est à dire que ceux qui reviennent
sont ceux qui ne sont pas partis en fait
ils vont rester à ne rien faire
la mobilisation qui était prévu était
une mobilisation massive alors ce qui
s'est passé c'est une guerre de guérilla
les guerres de la libération sur des
guerres de guérilla on n'a jamais eu
besoin de mobiliser l'armée française
donc les projets de carmine ne sont
connus que très peu de gens rené car
mieux
par son action dans la résistance et en
liaison avec les différentes
organisations de résistance illustre à
lui seul le rôle des obscurs de ceux qui
sont restés anonymes et pourtant qui ont
donné leur vie pour la france une france
libre
[Musique]
on
c'est donc cela histoire du fondateur de
mon école cette histoire dont on ne m'a
jamais parlé je comprends mieux
maintenant les silences
d'un côté rené carmi a tout du héros sa
vie sacrifiée pour le pays son génie
visionnaire et la richesse qu'il nous en
laisse
mais d'un autre côté il a ouvert la voie
au fichage général de la population à la
collecte de données en masse et à leur
utilisation policière
[Musique]
l'histoire de karmi est très
intéressante parce que elle pose des
questions qui sont en fait extrêmement
contemporaine il faut toujours imaginer
que ces outils qu'on déploie pourront
être demain utilisé à d'autres fins ou
pourront tomber entre de mauvaises mains
à la faveur d'élections
et donc ça nécessite je trouve un
principe de précaution qui aujourd'hui
n'est absolument pas appliquée on
n'existe pas du tout en matière
technologique
[Musique]
pour protéger nos droits dans les années
70 la france a bien créé la commission
nationale informatique et libertés mais
aujourd'hui elle n'a plus qu'un rôle
consultatif sur la création de fichiers
de police un contrôle sans contrainte
aujourd'hui on nous explique que
finalement on devrait faire confiance à
l'état et que l'état y est plus digne de
confiance que le sont les grandes
plateformes par exemple je crois qu'il
faut toujours être un peu maximaliste en
matière de technologie parce qu'au jour
d'aujourd'hui on a des fichiers de
police qui sont à la lisière quand même
de ceux de ce profilage politique
philosophique religieux
ethniques e syndicales et c'est
extrêmement préoccupant
pourquoi préoccupant parce qu'hier on
voulait pouvoir identifier de façon
certaine les français grâce au numéro de
sécurité sociale le meilleur moyen de
croiser tous les fichiers les concernant
mais désormais notre visage s'annonce
comme notre nouvel identifiant grâce à
la reconnaissance faciale elle ouvre la
voie à un contrôle d'identité permanent
et général
on peut falsifier un numéro
d'identification surtout à l'époque de
rené carmi où la police ne dispose pas
de dispositif qui permettait de vérifier
en temps réel quoi que ce soit donc à
l'époque la falsification et est
relativement aisé aujourd'hui on utilise
la biométrie de plus en plus et falsifié
son visage beaucoup beaucoup plus
content nul n'échappera à cette
identification de permanente ni à cette
vision de moderne du carnet signalétique
imaginé par car non au fichage total qui
croise toutes les données concernant
chaque individu et les rassemble sur
leur visage
[Musique]
en chine la dystopie est devenu réalité
et les premiers à en pâtir sont bien sûr
les minorités
aujourd'hui les ouigours jin chang
petite minorité musulmane qui subirent
un génocide culturel perpétrés par le
pouvoir central béninois c'est une
population qui était pieds dans le
moindre de ses faits et gestes vous
pouvez plus faire un pas dans la rue
sans être suivi par des caméras de
reconnaissance faciale voire même
parfois par des caméras qui maintenant
dante de détecter vos émotions ou
d'analysé votre démarche
sicard me découvrais le monde de 2021 il
serait peut-être assez effrayés
justement de voir la manière dont il a
peut-être contribué à ouvrir la boîte de
pandore qui aujourd'hui est extrêmement
difficile à arleux fermé refermer la
boîte appuyez sur le bouton stop est ce
encore possible
toute cette technologie s'en vante dans
la silicon valley près de san francisco
et vous savez quoi c'est la première
ville au monde à interdire toute
utilisation policière de la
reconnaissance faciale
si l'on regarde dans l'histoire ce sont
les catégories marginalisées de la
population qui ont été des plus soumise
aux abus des technologies de
surveillance et ce de façon
disproportionnée
la reconnaissance faciale est une
technologie particulièrement dangereuse
et oppressive comme ce qui se passe
actuellement en chine avec les ouigours
en tant que responsable politique nous
avons le devoir de protéger nos
concitoyens contre les potentiels abus
de ces technologies
[Musique]
j'aurais bien aimé que l'histoire de
rené car me soit connue
qu'on me l'apprennent à l'école
on me dise tu n'aura le droit de toucher
à ces données que si tu est consciente
des dangers qu'elle représente
mais surtout ce que je souhaite
aujourd'hui ah non pas du début de ma
vie professionnelle c'est que cette
technologie que nous statisticiens avons
entre les mains ne devienne pas les
armes de demain
[Musique]